madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce 19 20
george bush a réuni un véritable conseil
de guerre dans sa résidence de camp
david
la riposte américaine est annoncée les
états unis veulent se venger des
attaques terroristes
quatre jours après le drame les
recherches se poursuivent dans les
décombres du pentagone et du world trade
center mais au fil des heures l'espoir
de retrouver des survivants
sam wagne le commandant massoud est mort
son décès a été rendue officielle par le
gouvernement afghan en exil le chef de
l'opposition armée aux talibans avait
été victime d'un attentat dimanche
dernier nous sommes en guerre nous
riposterons le moment venu les propos de
george bush sont claires les états unis
préparent la vengeance à quand des vies
d'aujourd'hui le président américain a
commencé à mettre au point les plans de
riposte
hier soir déjà à new york alors qu'il
découvrait pour la première fois les
dégâts provoqués par les attentats
george bush acclamé par la foule avait
haussé le ton ou enel le noir hier soir
1ère avertissement
sur les ruines du world trade center
george bush assure aux sauveteurs que
les attentats ne resteront pas impunis
je vous entends
et le reste du monde vous entend
et les gens qui ont détruit ses
bâtiments vont aussi bientôt nous
entendre
nation cet après midi à camp david
entouré de son gouvernement le président
américain désigné oussama ben laden
comme le commanditaire et posément ils
menacent ils essaieront de se cacher au
tchad ils essaieront d'éviter les
etats-unis et leurs alliés pour la voir
mais on ne lâchera pas courir dans les
collines ils pourront se cacher dans des
trous nous on fera tout ce que je trouve
pour les enfumer pour les sortir de leur
trou et on essaiera est toujours aussi
calme
il affiche sa détermination sans faille
mon discours à la radio aujourd'hui j'ai
expliquer aux américains qu'il faudra
combien de temps aussi longtemps qu'il
le faut ça ne s'agit pas d'une seule
personne
nous tiendrons aussi pour responsables
ceux qui les ont nourris ce qu'ils ont
et bien george bush a les états unis
derrière loin selon un sondage 80% des
américains sont favorables à la
liquidation des responsables des
attentats et déjà des centaines de
jeunes se sont engagés dans l'armée
américaine est sur le terrain les
grandes manoeuvres ont commencé si la
défense américaine n'était en état d'
alerte maximum un niveau jamais atteint
selon le washington post depuis l'
attaque japonaise de pearl harbour en 41
l'aviation et la flotte américaine se
met en place
tandis qu aux etats unis plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de réservistes sont
déjà prêts à reprendre l'uniforme
pierre babey le rappel de 50000
réservistes c'est le premier pour
l'instant le seul indice de préparatifs
militaires
ces soldats du dimanche comme on les
appelle affectueusement au portage de
remplacer les soldats professionnels qui
eux sont mobilisés pour des missions de
guerre sont les théâtres d'opération le
théâtre d'opérations justement pour
l'instant à l'absence de toute cible
précise
c'est la zone très vaste du moyen-orient
des forces américaines ils sont déjà
déployés principalement des unités
navales et aériennes dans les centres
opérationnels
on repasse à toute vitesse en revue des
scénarios d'intervention et dans les
armureries on vérifie les munitions
c'est tout pour l'instant car quelle
opération une opération clandestine à
base de commando aéroporté semble pour
l'instant avoir été écarté trop risqué
pour un résultat trop aléatoire et
surtout pas assez visible reste l'option
lourde style tempête du désert il y a
dix ans les opérations contre l'irak
avait nécessité six mois de mise en
place et l'acheminement des etats-unis
vers l'arabie saoudite d'un corps
expéditionnaire de cinq cent mille
soldats américains
seulement la cible supposée
l'afghanistan n'est pas l'irak en cas
d'intervention terrestre
il faudrait passer par le pakistan à
tout le moins réservé ou par le nord
mais avec l'accord des russes
aujourd'hui comme celle à islamabad le
ministre des affaires étrangères du
pakistan déclare que son pays est contre
le soutien au terrorisme international
mais qu'il est contre aussi
l'utilisation de son pays riches comme
base arrière d'une intervention
extérieure
comme un écho dans la rue manifestation
anti américaine et pro ben laden cet
après midi à islamabad
dans le même temps en afghanistan cible
supposée d'une éventuelle intervention
américaine
on assiste ici à kaboul au départ d'une
partie de la population pour fuir
d'éventuels bombardements comme sur
bagdad
il y a dix ans l'opération s'appelait
alors tempête du désert
le président américain était au milieu
de ses boys il s'appelait george bush
déjà et pendant ce temps-là manhattan le
ballet des pelleteuses et des bulldozer
se poursuit les secouristes sont
fatigués forcément l'espoir de retrouver
des survivants s'amenuise d'heure en
heure
d'ailleurs depuis deux jours maintenant
aucun rescapé n'a été sorti des
décombres
didier ben régnant dans ce château de
cartes qui menace à tout moment de
s'effondrer
les sauveteurs continuent leur travail
de fourmi
l'édifice est si fragile que c'est à
mains nues que les opérations de
recherche continuent mais au fil des
heures
l'espoir de retrouver des survivants
s'amenuise depuis mercredi aucun rescapé
n'a été extraits des décombres
seuls des corps sans vie sont exhumés
mais les sauveteurs s'accroche encore
ils veulent croire au miracle que l'on
trouve quelqu'un on espère qu'il sera
vivant malheureusement mon chien a
trouvé 14 cadavres
on a toujours de l'espoir et je vais
rester ici jusqu'à ce qu'on trouve
d'autres personnes dans les ruines du
world trade center 2000 pompiers se
relaient 24 heures sur 24
mais les héros sont fatigués et meurtri
on prendra conscience quand on sera de
retour dans nos familles et depuis des
jours dans leurs postes médicaux avancés
les médecins se sentent bien inutile de
démoralisant quand tout est prêt pour
aider les blessés et que personne ne
vient entre la seule chose que vous ayez
à faire c'est de prendre soin des
blessures des secouristes
désespéré ne sachant plus vers qui se
tourner les familles placardent dans les
rues des photos les portraits de leurs
proches disparus
le sud de manhattan est devenue un
immense mémorial où l'on s'active
inlassablement à détecter le moindre
souffle de vie à new york la solidarité
envers les victimes est visible à chaque
coin de rue et les volontaires sont de
plus en plus nombreux à vouloir aider
les secouristes mais devant les risques
d'effondrement et à cause d'une
suspicion grandissante et bien les
autorités ont été obligées de limiter le
nombre
deux bénévoles sur place le reportage de
nos envoyés spéciaux jean marc pitte et
pierre dick
d'ici quelques heures demain peut-être
jeff reprendra la route pour la floride
ce mécanicien de 33 ans et a couru le
plus vite possible pour proposer son
aide
mais aujourd'hui les volontaires sont
presque systématiquement refusées et 15h
et 16h à cause du danger à cause de ce
qu'il y à découvrir là bas j'ai parlé à
des gens qui étaient sur place au début
ça semble être l'heureux ils veulent
maintenant que tu sois organisée et
contrôlée par le gouvernement
des rumeurs prétendaient également que
de faux bénévoles malintentionnés se
sont transformés en pilleurs dès qu'ils
ont été autorisés à se rendre sur la
zone
les autorités craignent aussi de voir
des éléments de preuve disparaître
christophe est français il vit à new
york depuis dix ans et s'est porté
volontaire ce matin mais il comprend cet
état d'esprit de défiance engendrés par
les attentats barman ans ils se sentent
vulnérables avant ils se sentaient c'est
vrai que bon ils ont la grosse tête on
est les plus forts on est américain et
moi aussi je me sentais comme ça j'ai eu
besoin d'un miracle je suis venu ici à
10 ans est née là bon c'est vrai on est
vulnérable
d'autres français rongent leur frein en
attendant de se rendre utile ce sont dix
pompiers professionnels ou volontaires
membres d'une organisation non
gouvernementale du pas de calais c'est
la première ong française à avoir réussi
à acheminer ses membres à new york
ils sont maintenant à la recherche de
l'autorité qui leur permettra de
travailler
on y arriver cette nuit donc vers 23
heures et 1 minute mais on est arrivés
sur le site impots timité du site à
quelques mètres du site
on était accompagné par le fbi haye qui
était d'accord de l'onf est rentré après
vérification malheureusement le vieil
ami les ordres et on devait faire
vérifier notre matériel pour des risques
d'attentats on comprend tout à fait
malheureusement actuellement on sait pas
qui peut vérifier notre matériel et
personne ne peut nous donner de réponse
ces volontaires derrière moi ont eu plus
de chance ils font partie d'un syndicat
et leurs propositions des dons étaient
collectivement accepté
ils attendent ici depuis 7h ce matin le
prochain bus et pour eux il va les
emmener sur le site où ils ont encore
l'espoir de retrouver des survivants
il est 19 heures 40 en france 13h40 à
new york où nous retrouvons direct
carine azzopardi karine seuls six
survivants ont été retrouvés depuis
marty un chiffre malheureusement très
très faible les familles des disparus
garde-t-elle néanmoins espoir
je reviens à l'instant du centre
d'urgence d'accueil des familles de
disparus
il ya des centaines de personnes des
milliers de personnes qui se pressent la
base sur les trottoirs ou les photos des
disparus sont placardées un peu partout
sur les boîtes aux lettres les cabines
téléphoniques un peu partout mais là bas
on en est encore absolument pas au deuil
il ya encore dans chaque regard un
espoir fou et on s'accroche vraiment à
ce goût de disparus j'ai rencontré
plusieurs personnes cherchant des
proches
une jeune femme qui cherchait
désespérément son fiancé son fiancé
travail au deuxième étage de la deuxième
tour l'avion qui s'est crashé dans cette
tour s'est crashé au 51e étage donc
comment peut-on encore garder espoir
après ça mais si à gardel cherche dans
la rue elle se précipite sur les
télévisions pour montrer la photo de son
fiancé elle demande à chacun de devis
sylvie quelqu'un a vu son cette personne
des histoires comme celle-là on peut
rencontrer des centaines par des
milliers dans tout manhattan
mais je ne sais pas si on peut vraiment
parler des espoirs sérieux c'est fou que
cela puisse paraître les gens toujours
une once d'espoir ici
et malgré l'épuisement des sauveteurs
les recherches bien sûr se poursuivent
encore à l'heure actuelle
oui et les autorités ont mis en place
plusieurs nouvelles choses pour tenter
de retrouver soi déçoit des survivants
soient des soins d'identifier les corps
d'abord un numéro qui permet qui permet
aux gens de donner le portable des
personnes disparues et il ya enfin
techniquement il essaie de repérer les
corps ou des survivants avec les
portables en appelant les portables et
ans
en localisant et portables les autorités
demandent aussi aux familles d'apporter
des preuves adn des brosses à dents des
morceaux de cheveux qui permettent
d'identifier les corps merci carine
azzopardi en direct de new york
parmi les 5000 portés disparus des tours
du world trade center figurent tous les
employés d'une des plus importantes
sociétés de courtage au monde
les 700 salariés qui se trouvaient dans
les bureaux au sommet de la tour numéro
1 ont péri je vous propose d'écouter le
pdg de cette firme en pleurs howard
lutnick raconte le drame dans lequel il
a également perdu son frère mon frère
était au 103e étage et travailler pour
moi pour notre société la candeur
il a une autre soeur juste après que
l'avion ait percuté la tour
il a dit qu'il suffoque et à cause de la
fumée
s'il était coincé dans son bureau où ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas moyen de sortir je
crois qu'il se savait déjà perdu et
voulais juste lui dire qu'il l'aimé et
vous nous dire au revoir et nous dire
qu'il nous aimait et puis les téléphones
ont été coupées je suis le patron de la
compagnie je n'étais pas là et je ne
pouvais même pas joindre et d'aimer 700
employés
aucun d'eux j'ai vu le building en feu
dès que je suis arrivé sur place
je ne pouvais pas y aller j'ai attendu
le plus près possible pour voir ce
qu'ils sortaient je leur ai hurlé de
courir le plus vite possible
réfugié demander aux gens d'où ils
venaient de quel étage mes employés
étaient entre le sens et le 105
je voulais qu'il s'en sorte mais les
gens me disaient sont bien dus 55 du 55
seulement
et puis la tour s'est effondrée je suis
resté là tétanisé comme un idiot
après j'ai commencé à courir j'ai essayé
d'échapper à la fumée mais je pensais à
eux
personne n'avait s'en sortir il faut
continuer à travailler parce que seule
cette compagnie peut aider les familles
des 700 employés disparus 700 familles
700 personnes et à washington les
recherches se poursuivent également au
pentagone gravement endommagé lui aussi
par l'avion kamikaze le travail continue
dans les décombres du ministère de la
défense où le bilan devrait être environ
2 300 morts voici les premières images
de l'intérieur du bâtiment détruit
pierre didier d'abord le point d'impact
vu du ciel et ce trou béant dans
l'enceinte du pentagone et puis
l'intérieur dévastée il eût sanctuaire
militaire américain ses bureaux ses
couloirs ont été parcourus par la boule
de feu sur des centaines de milliers de
mètres carrés et ce responsable du
pentagone
au fur et à mesure qu'il progresse
les secours doivent étayé murs et
plafonds menacé d'effondrement
pour l'heure le bilan fait état de 189
morts mais 125 personnes qui
travaillaient mardi au pentagone sont
toujours portées disparues les
sauveteurs poursuivent leurs recherches
dans cette aile ouest qui venait d'être
rénové mais déjà hier les deux tiers du
pentagone fonctionnaient à nouveau
normalement
et pendant que l'amérique compte ses
morts et préparent la riposte le fbi lui
poursuit ses investigations pour la
première fois depuis mardi les agents
fédéraux ont procédé à une
interpellation
des arrestations ont également eu lieu
en allemagne aux pays-bas et en belgique
alors qu aux etats unis les enquêteurs
s'intéressent de très près aux écoles de
pilotage où les kamikazes se seraient
formées armée le charrier en arizona
c'est dans cette école de pilotage que
aniane genre a été formé c'est un des
passagers de l'avion qui s'est écrasé
sur le pentagone
selon le fbi ce serait un des pirates de
l'air une fois de plus l'amérique
apprend que c'est sur son sol que les
kamikazes ont pu s'entraîner en toute
discrétion
il avait réservé plusieurs mois
d'entraînement en 1996 qu'il n'a pas
effectué il a tout bonnement disparu
avant de revenir en janvier 1997 pour
quelques cours supplémentaires ces
formations pilotage permettent de mieux
comprendre le parcours des terroristes
au bourget en france une société de
simulation de vol flight safety
internationale a donc remis le fichier
le sa clientèle à la dst une clientèle
composée en grande partie de
ressortissants du moyen orient
et c'est au travers de tous les milieux
islamistes que les enquêteurs cherchent
à cerner le réseau de ben laden une
piste supplémentaire en allemagne
un libanais étaient dans l'avion qui
s'est écrasé en pennsylvanie est lui
aussi s'intéresser au pilotage
eto'o est sourd les recherches que nous
avons mené à bochum ils nous ont permis
de découvrir une valise abandonnée à
l'intérieur nous avons trouvé des
documents ayant trait aux avions
cet homme fréquenté la même école
hambourg et les mêmes milieux islamistes
que deux autres membres du commando
super en belgique
deux islamistes ont été inculpés est là
pour tentative de destruction d'édifices
par explosion rien ne confirme son
appartenance à la mouvance ben laden
mais on a retrouvé chez lui un arsenal
militaire aux états unis le fbi a
procédé à une seule arrestation
les enquêteurs ont retrouvé aujourd'hui
la deuxième boîte noire de l'avion
abattu à pittsburgh
une boîte noire très importante elle
contiendrait l'enregistrement des
conversations à bord du cockpit
enfin le fbi a rendu public sur internet
la liste des 19 terroristes présents
dans les avions
une liste qui a déjà suscité des
milliers d'appels
les enquêteurs s'intéressent également
aux méthodes de communication des réseau
d'oussama ben laden des procédés très
sophistiqués pour échanger des
informations en toute discrétion pour
eux internet est une arme redoutable et
les sites sur lesquels ils surf vous
allez le voir sont très éloignés du
fondamentalisme religieux
dominique vadel alexandre dupont le site
est ultra protégée car dans son
laboratoire
chaque halte à b analyse toutes les
perversions d'internet et pour lui c'est
comme ça que les terroristes ont pu
opérer démonstration sur un site
érotique il sélectionne une photo et la
recopie ensuite ils écrivent leurs
messages avant de déterminer l'endroit
où le dissimuler là c'est un jeu
d'enfant
il change la couleur du texte pour
arriver à le fondre dans le noir des
cheveux le message ne se voit plus mais
il est pourtant toujours bien là un clic
et la photo et le texte se retrouve sur
un site choisi avec les complices
l'opération en sens inverse peut
commencer la couleur du texte 10 rue les
retravailler l'original réapparait bref
c'est simple et imparable
il n'y a pas d'obstacle à converser par
des messages en fouillant les images et
les mettra à n'importe quel endroit du
monde sur les sites internet que des
correspondants vont après aller
consulter quand il le veut en france à
votre avis il ya déjà eu des exactions
de cette sorte
je pense que malheureusement c'est aussi
le cas pour des gens plus ou moins
lointain est là pour protéger leurs
manoeuvres
les terroristes ont eu sans doute
recours à un logiciel de cryptage
disponible lui aussi sur internet
à la suite des attentats de mardi
certains leaders radicaux de la
communauté musulmane de londres ont tenu
des propos très virulents à l'encontre
des états unis londres qui avec
l'allemagne est considérée comme l'une
des bases arrières de l'intégrisme
musulman en europe sur place le
reportage de stéphanie des jarres et
benoît véran à la mosquée de finsbury de
très fervents fidèles attirés par un
discours radical viennent parfois de
loin pour la prière du vendredi
leur chef de file celui qui prêche ici
c'est cheikh hamza très connu à londres
pour ses positions anti américaines
réitéré même après les attentats
à la sortie de la prière des militants
distribuent des tracts devant les
journalistes il les appelle talion
contre l'impérialisme occidental
la guerre va se déplacer jusqu ici en
grande bretagne
ça va venir jusqu'ici en grande bretagne
voulaient voir le sang en angleterre
nous les musulmans sévère nous sommes
pas contre les sud américains nous ne
sommes pas contre les citoyens
britanniques
nous sommes contre l'occupation
américaine les fidèles acquiesce mais ne
sont pas autorisés à parler le service
d'ordre de la mosquée qui a filmé les
journalistes pendant le prêche y veille
ces militants sont issus du front
islamique de la charia une organisation
dirigée par cet homme cheikh omar bakri
lui aussi a fait sa réputation sur ses
positions anti-américaines
aujourd'hui il condamne les attentats
contre des civils mais menace aussi les
gouvernements occidentaux
il y à 50 millions de musulmans en
occident
et si vous jouez avec le feu vous allez
créer un monstre à votre porte
croyez-moi si quelqu'un décide de se
crasher comme cela s'est produit
cela donne des idées à tout le monde
cela fait des martyrs et personne ne
pourra empêcher cela aucun système ne
pourra arrêter quelqu'un qui est prêt à
mourir pour la gloire de dieu
ces prises de position ont été condamnés
par le parlement islamique britannique
une fédération représentant 350
organisations musulmanes plus modérée
aujourd'hui eux craignent que cette
polémique ne nuise à l'ensemble de la
communauté musulmane
depuis cinq jours les services secrets
sont sur le pied de guerre en direct
avec nous de draguignan nous retrouvons
l'ancien directeur de la dst bernard
charbon soir vous étiez la torche
bonsoir bonsoir vous étiez le patron du
contre espionnage français entre 86 et
90 au moment de la vague d'attentats à
paris nous en parlerons dans quelques
instants
on a de plus en plus l'impression
bernard gérard que les services secrets
américains en fait sous-estimer la
menace qui planait sur les etats-unis
vous pensez vous que ces attentats
auraient pu être évités et côté de toute
façon où que l'on soit lorsque les
attentats se produisent
on a toujours le sentiment d'avoir
sous-estimé les moyens employés là sur
un pays aux immenses où les minorités
sensibles sont multiples dans ce pays de
multiples en ce pays là il n'est pas
très facile dû faire du renseignement de
proximité comme nous avions l'habitude
de le faire
est-ce qu est-ce que selon vous la sept
ou huit ans de guerre terroriste
est-ce que selon vous la cia n'a pas un
peu trop oublié justement le
renseignement humain dont vous venez de
parler de lui le travail en fait des
espions et qu'ils ont trop privilégié
peut-être la haute technologie sans
doute sans doute et nous entendons plus
d'ailleurs les propos sur la pointe etc
nos logiques des américains que sur
d'autres sujets il faut quand même faire
la part des choses
la technologie nous l'utilisions
également ne serait ce qu en utilisant
les premiers akers qui ne disait pas qui
ne disait pas ce nom l'année ce qui ne
s'appelait pas comme ça et qu'ils
étaient de jeunes informaticiens que
nous utilisions tous les changeant tous
les deux ans la démission très
ponctuelle par exemple mais nous
utilisions également des procédés
techniques mécaniques les technologies
étaient moins sophistiqué qu'aujourd'hui
justement bernard gérard et avons pu
pardon soyons par ces moyens là que vous
aviez pu à l'époque faire tomber les
réseaux iranien en france à paris
notamment à la fin des années 80 c'est
surtout du fait de notre possibilité de
pénétrer les minorités qui sur lesquels
s'appuyait le hezbollah
amiens est également en introduisant en
intoxiquant en ayant de multiples
sources dans la périphérie
il y à des lieux que message on
connaissait comme leur poche la mosquée
à l'helvète un certain nombre de sites à
paris en province c'est là où nous avons
trouvé à la suite de l' annonce une
récompense les gens qui sont venus nous
apporter des informations
et puis nous avons progressé aussi il
faut le dire avec la collaboration entre
les services
on parle très souvent de la guerre des
polices dans cette période des années 80
nous avions déjà dix années d'attentats
de prise d'otage derrière nous et croyez
moi cette coopération était totale au
ministère de l'intérieur et en réunion
interministérielle hebdomadaire monsieur
jara opération aussi avec les services
occidentaux
pardonnez moi à l'époque où vous étiez
allé plus loin à l'époque vous étiez le
patron de la dst est ce que vous avez
vous redoutez des attaques terroristes
menées par des avions kamikaze comme ce
fut le cas mardi ou c'était de la
science fiction alors que je voulais
résulté simplement la phrase que j'ai
tenu tenu avant nous avions également
une collaboration de solidarité avec un
certain nombre de services arabe et une
relation technique continu protéger avec
l'ensemble de ses services
alors je réponds à l'autre question
c'est la plus importante si lorsque nous
avons pu écouter pendant quelques jours
les équipes qui allaient qui apportait
des explosifs qu'ils allaient lancer une
vague nouvelle d'attentats nous avons
entendu dans cette logorrhée propre aux
gens qui sont en prière ou en guerre ça
n'est jamais très net surtout avec
clichy
nous avons entendu en fin de
l'imagination
cette ce propos vous verrez un avion
suicide se plonger sur une solution une
usine nucléaire et vous verrez les
français courir sur les routes
goudronnées
c'est encore possible aujourd'hui c'est
encore possible henrion disque-là
existe-t-il bien sûr mais les
protections mises en place en termes de
résistance dans les centrales nucléaires
en france notamment
nous sommes quand même les champions de
la sécurité sont extrêmement sérieux
bernard gérard merci d'avoir été
avec nous merci pour toutes ces
explications les talibans et oussama ben
laden ne viennent de remporter une
nouvelle victoire puisque c'est
désormais officiel le commandant massoud
est mort l'ambassade afghane à moscou
c'est à dire l'opposition en exil a
confirmé le décès du chef militaire le
commandant massoud victime d'un attentat
dimanche dernier a donc succombé à ses
blessures
hervé dit non l'une des dernières
interviews du commandant massoud
il recevait un sénateur et des
journalistes français et évoqué la
menace ben laden lors d'un entretien
ultérieur le 10 septembre dernier ces
deux heures multi prétendent être des
journalistes travaillant pour une agence
de presse arabes font exploser leurs
caméras piéger le commandant massoud est
grièvement blessé durant quatre jours
ils luttent entre la vie et la mort hier
soir le commandant massoud a rendu les
armes
héros de la résistance à l'envahisseur
soviétique de 1979 à 1989
le commandant était entré triomphalement
dans kaboul en 1992
mais quatre ans plus tard il est chassé
de la ville par les talibans depuis il
vivait retranché dans le nord-est du
pays dans le paint scheer il ne
contrôlait plus que 5% du territoire
au mois d'avril dernier à l'invitation
du parlement européen
il s'était rendu à strasbourg une
occasion de dénoncer le soutien apporté
par le pakistan aux talibans
et de demander de l'aide il arrêter
vraiment
très heureux de pouvoir s'exprimer
justement devant tous les présidents des
groupes politiques du parlement européen
d'avoir été entendus par cette
communauté européenne et à travers nous
parler 370 millions de citoyens
européens que leur présentant un succès
d'estimé certes mais comme le rappelait
ses sympathisants réunis cet après midi
à paris massoud n'avait pas réellement
été entendu aujourd'hui le peuple
allemand se bat combat le commerce
international
mohammad ben laden et services secrets
pakistanais et ce sont les mêmes
théories qui ont commis les attentats
aux états unis qui sont à l'origine de
russie que l'attentât les sympathisants
de massoud veulent délivrer un autre
message attention à l'amalgamé entre
terroristes et peuple afghan et alors
que tous les regards sont tournés vers
les états unis après les attentats le
conflit israëlo palestinien se durcit
avec même une nouvelle flambée de
violence matin l'armée israélienne a
lancé des attaques sur des positions
palestiniennes dans la bande de gaza
faisant plusieurs blessés
par ailleurs un adolescent palestinien
de 14 ans a été tué par balles dans des
affrontements
les affrontements qui ont éclaté après
les funérailles de deux autres
palestiniens tués l'année dernière la
nouvelle tension qui augure mal d'une
rencontre prochaine entre yasser arafat
shimon peres on ne peut pas parler de
psychose mais les fausses alertes à la
bombe se sont multipliées ces dernières
48 heures comme c'est souvent le cas
d'ailleurs en période de vives tensions
sur le plan international à strasbourg à
lyon mais aussi en région parisienne ou
encore à lille les services de déminage
ont été très sollicités le reportage à
lille justement devient nasa qui est
géré marignan
11 heures la gare lille-europe bondé et
évacué de valise suspecte ont été
repérés l'une dans le hall l'autre dans
une rame tgv une partie du trafic et des
tournées sur la gare lille flandres mais
beaucoup de passagers sont bloqués
lyon vous attendez deux artificiers de
la police de l'air et des frontières
interviennent il s'agit simplement de
bagages perdus ou abandonnés 14 heures
la gare est rouverte aux voyageurs après
trois heures d'attenté lui et puis il
faut maintenant ceux qui étaient en
français on peut pas perdre hier soir
c'est la gare d'arras qui a dû être
évacué pour le même motif
une heure plus tôt c'était tout un
quartier de villeneuve d'ascq est
bouclée en raison d'une voiture suspecte
à chaque fois la procédure est la même
un périmètre de sécurité délimité
policiers pompiers démineurs
interviennent jusqu'à ce que tout danger
soit écarté
pourtant ces fausses alertes une
douzaine en cinq jours seulement
non pas vraiment d'incidence sur les
comportements je ne peux pas quand je
suis rentré enfin quand j'étais en bas
au parquet je me suis dit et pensé
maintenant bon je pensais plutôt
psychose qui savait quoi
tu as dû à l'impact de
ces partitions il faut dire que la
plupart de ces fausses alertes émane de
coups de téléphone anonymes des blagues
macabre qui peuvent coûter cher jusqu'à
2 ans d'emprisonnement et 220 mille
francs d'amendé
la fête de l'humanité qui se tient ce
week-end à la courneuve s'est ouverte
sur fond d'attentes anti-américain des
événements qui sont bien sûr au coeur de
tous les débats
le parti communiste condamne évidemment
ces attaques mais les militants veulent
faire entendre leur différence
concernant notamment la politique
américaine en matière de représailles
le reportage de stéphane grand et
georges mingoua apparemment robert hue
et décontractée bizot militante et
signatures d'autographes tout va bien
pourtant l'ombre des attentats de new
york et washington plane sur la tête de
l'uimm
bien sûr le pc a condamné vivement les
actions terrorisme mais se pose le
problème de l' après celui des ripostes
et la robert hue a choisi de faire
entendre sa différence
il faut parler le langage de la paix en
s'engageant pour un règlement sans
tarder de la tragédie du proche orient
qui gangrène l'ensemble de la vie
internationale
il faut parler paix en tendant la main
du dialogue et de la coopération aux
états et aux peuples qui se revendique
comme isla dans l'ensemble d'ailleurs ce
sentiment est largement partagé par les
camarades entre deux animations festives
dont phil 8 participer au débat est là
toujours les mêmes interrogations
qu'elle rit aux quelles actions à mener
les militants ne cachent pas leur
inquiétude
le peuple américain ne méritait pas ça
mais les gouvernants américains quelque
part de vérité
pourquoi parce que y'a ya trop d'abus de
cette force
allez la seule dirige brook comex
longtemps d'ailleurs s'il faut résoudre
le problème des pressions politiques
sans avoir sans résoudre le problème du
moyen-orient point de vue politique
c'est pas possible de résoudre le
problème du terrorisme
il faut donc aller avec des moyens
politiques d'abord et puis peut-être
aussi avec des moyens militaires mais ça
c'est secondaire
bref un véritable cas de conscience pour
les militants communistes et bourreau
bérus et d'un nouvel exercice de grand
écart pas forcément facile à appréhender
pour le mot d'ordre général se résume
quand même
un appel général à la piscine et selon
un sondage ipsos à paraître demain dans
le journal du dimanche une forte
majorité de français se dit favorable à
une participation de la france à une
éventuelle action militaire des états
unis vous le voyez 78% sont pour 68%
pardon sont pour
en revanche 21% des personnes
interrogées se déclarent hostiles à
cette hypothèse
ce soir dans tous les stades de football
une minute de silence sera observée en
hommage aux victimes des attentats
ce fut le cas cet après midi à gerland
où l'olympique lyonnais recevait le
football club de nantes
et côté sportif lyon s'est facilement
imposé 4 buts à 1 grâce notamment au
premier but d'eric carrière sous ses
nouvelles couleurs l'ancien joueur de
nantes permet donc à lyon de prendre
provisoirement la tête du championnat
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi dans un instant la météo
complète de jean marx ou amish le
dernier journal le soir 3 à 23h40 avec
qui jean sébastien fernandez excellente
soirée et à demain pour le 12 14 et le